I don't think so,
some of the basic outlook as it would be
that people are monkeys with large
brains,
period.
And uh,
that's the way you have to think about
it.
Um,
it,
it does,
it does make me cynical about human
motivation and it,
it makes me think,
you just have to be very practical,
very realistic.
I don't,
I don't have,
I don't put any,
any faith in a utopian.
A drain was,
I don't think people are basically good
or anything like that.
Um,
you know,
the promises of politicians and the,
and the Bologna that judges spew out and
their opinions.
I think when one wants to,
Oh,
uh,
have a caustic view of,
of,
of people,
of all people,
you know,
you have to be
no recognize if it's severe problems
with criminality.
We also have problems with a no abuse of
authority and,
and with a mistreatment of all sorts of
people and
overextension of criminal laws,
excessive criminal sentences.
So the,
the,
the problems are everywhere.
I,
I very much dislike the extremes of left
and right.
Um,
and anything that is faith based,
whether it's religious or whether it's
a,
I mean they,
you know,
the left there just as religious,
they don't have a god,
my sister's religious in the sense that
it's a,
that is based on faith rather than fact.
So I think we should always be trying
to,
you know,
penetrate to the level of fact.
Now the criticism of this,
of the pragmatic position is that it's
not enough to know what the facts are.
I know what the consequences are because
they have to be valued.
You can't,
you know,
there's a disjunction between,
isn't you can infer a lot from as I
agree with that,
but,
but there is a degree of consensus and
society.
So they didn't actually know the
consequences of,
um,
of particular
policies,
uh,
that most people will be brought to
because there's a basic moral
man.
I don't like moralistic vocabulary,
moralistic reasoning.
But obviously there is more,
there are people have moral
feelings,
they do react to things.
So you know,
if everything was known about abortion,
who gets it,
why there are other ways of preventing
that,
this and that.
The other thing,
he really understood it.
I think we would
get most people,
not 100 percent,
but maybe 60 percent would think,
yes,
this is what and how is she.